>>> WITH JUST DAYS TO GO BEFORE
THE FIRST ANNIVERSARY OF THE
DEADLY INSURRECTION OF THE
CAPITOL, A SOURCE SAYING THAT
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE HAS
FIRSTHAND INFORMATION FROM
MULTIPLE SOURCES ON WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WAS DOING AS
THE ATTACK UNFOLDED.
A LOT TO DISCUSS WITH JOHN
KASICH, THE FORMER REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR OF OHIO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU.
>> SAME TO YOU.
>> WE'RE STARTING TO LEARN WHAT
WAS GOING ON INSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE.
TRUMP WAS WATCHING TELEVISION
AND RESISTING CALLS, EVEN FROM
HIS OWN FAMILY.
MEANWHILE, THE HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY IS BLAMING
SECURITY LAPSES AT THE CAPITOL.
WHY IS MOST OF THE GOP ABSOLVING
TRUMP OF THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, DON, THERE IS A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO I THINK HAVE
HAVING A BREAK WITH REALITY.
IN OTHER WORDS, NO MATTER WHAT
THE FACTS ARE, THEY JUST WANT TO
DISASSOCIATE THEMSELVES FROM ANY
OF THE FACTS AND WHEN POLITICS
BECOMES A THIRST FOR POWER, DON,
FOR ANYBODY, OR ALL THESE
PEOPLE, THIRST FOR POWER, I HATE
TO SAY THIS I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT
WHETHER I SHOULD SAY IT BUT THAT
UNRAVELS THE COUNTRY.
WHEN THEY WON'T EXCEPT THE
RESULT OF AN ELECTION.
WE SAW RICHARD NIXON IN A
CONTROVERSIAL DECISION TO
ACCEPTED RESULTS OF A DECISION
BECAUSE THAT WAS PART OF THE
AMERICAN FABRIC.
THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO SEE
THE FACTS, PEOPLE THAT SEE THIS
AND SAY THERE WAS NO VIOLENCE
AND I SEE REPUBLICAN LEADERS
LOOKING THE OTHER WAY TRYING TO
MAKE EXCUSES, IT'S A THIRST FOR
POWER ON THEIR BEHALF AND FOR
THE PUBLIC, IT'S ALMOST
CULT-LIKE FOR SOME OF THE PEOPLE
OUT THERE IN THE PUBLIC.
I HEARD SOME OF THE INTERVIEWS
EARIER TODAY, PEOPLE SAYING
WELL TRUMP WOULD NEVER DO THIS.
THERE WAS NO VIOLENCE.
THAT IS BEING DISENGAGED FROM
REALITY AND NO MATTER WHAT WE
TELL THEM, THEY WON'T ACCEPT IT
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE IN A CULT AND
START TO DISTINGUISH YOURSELF OR
DISAGREE, THEY TRY TO EX
COMMUNICATE YOU.
I'M NOT SAYING THIS IS A CULT
BUT CULT-LIKISH.
IT'S SO SERIOUS.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S -- YOU SAID
A THIRST FOR POWER.
IS IT EVEN MORE SINISTER THAN
THAT OR I DON'T KNOW IF SINISTER
IS THE RIGHT WAY.
THERE IS A SOMETHING THAT GOES
ALONG WITH IT THAT PEOPLE THUMB
THEIR NOSE AT DEMOCRACY AND
FACTS AND TO CREATE THEIR OWN.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M
SAYING?
>> IT'S PEOPLE THAT GET
THEMSELVES  IN GROUPS AND
WHATEVER THE FACTS ARE, IT COULD
BE DAYLIGHT AND YOU SAY THE SUN
HAS COME UP AND THEY SAY NO, IT
HASN'T.
>> BUT IF THEY NOTICE --
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE --
>> IT'S LIKE SCREW YOU FOR
THINKING THE OTHER WAY.
GO ON, YEAH.
>> WELL, LOOK, YOU KNOW, ALSO
THE HATRED, YOU KNOW, WE CAN'T
DISAGREE WITH ANYBODY TODAY IN
THE COUNTRY.
NOW IT'S ABOUT HATRED.
WHEN WE STUDY HISTORY, DON, WHEN
WE STUDY HISTORY OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO OTHER GREAT POWERS
AND SEEN THEM MELT TO THE
GROUND, AMERICA HAS GOT SO MUCH
GOING FOR IT.
RIGHT?
WE'RE POWERFUL ECONOMICALLY.
WE'RE POWERFUL MILITARY BUT OUR
SOUL AND OUR SPIRIT RIGHT NOW,
DO WE -- DON, DO YOU THINK THAT
TODAY IN AMERICA WE SHARE SORT
OF THE SAME VALUES WE USED TO
WHEN YOU WERE A YOUNG MAN AND I
WAS A YOUNG MAN?
I THINK THOSE HAVE BEEN FRAYED
AND WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE A COMMON
PURPOSE AND COMMON VALUES, IT'S
NOT GOOD.
IT NEEDS TO BE RENEWED BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE LIKE ON BOTH SIDES
FIGHTING AND ARGUING.
YOU GOT TO STOP IT, FOLKS,
BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY JUST IS NOT
GREAT BECAUSE ALL OF A SUDDEN IT
WAS GREAT AND WILL ALWAYS BE
GREAT.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT IT.
THAT'S WHAT THE FOUNDERS TOLD
US, PROTECT THE COUNTRY.
>> THAT WAS ONE OF MY WISHES FOR
THE NEW YEAR, WE HAD A SHARED
REALITY THE I AND WE WOULD TRY
TO GIVE EACH OTHER AT LEAST A
BREAK OR I DON'T KNOW, TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN COME TO
SOME SORT OF SHARED REALITY OR
FACTS BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE
THAT, WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING.
JOHN, WHAT IS MORE DISTURBING.
LET ME PUT THIS UP.
34% OF AMERICANS THINK VIOLENT
ACTION AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT IS
SOMETIMES JUSTIFIED ACCORDING TO
THE WASHINGTON POST, A
WASHINGTON POST POLL.
JUST FOR CONTEXT, "THE POST"
SAID THIS WAS IN THE 90s, AS
MANY AS 90% SAID VIOLENCE WAS
NEVER JUSTIFIED.
ARE YOU WORRIED WHAT THAT MEANS
A YEAR OUT FROM JANUARY 6th?
>> WE HAVE DONE A LOT OF SHOWS
AND TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE FACT
WHEN PEOPLE WON'T ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF AN ELECTION, WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN?
NOW IT'S LIKE OKAY, WELL,
VIOLENCE IS OKAY.
I MEAN, THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE.
THINK ABOUT THIS, DON, WHO SEE
VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY THE 6th AND THEY LOOK AT
THE VIDEO AND GO IT NEVER
HAPPENED AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO
SAY, YOU KNOW, YOU GOT THAT
POLL, 30%, 30 PLUS PERCENT
SAYING VIOLENCE MAY BE JUSTIFIED
ON WHAT BASIS?
WHAT'S THE PRINCIPLE?
WHAT IS IT YOU'RE FIGHTING FOR?
FOR WHAT YOU WANT, FOR YOU
POWER, WHAT'S IN IT FOR YOU?
NOBODY ELSE MATTERS.
DON, THIS IS A SERIOUS DRIFT.
I HATE TO --
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> I DON'T LIKE TO SOUND ALARMS.
YOU NEVER HEAR ME SAY RADICAL
THINGS.
I'M TELLING YOU I'M WORRIED
ABOUT OUR COUNTRY.
>> I THINK MORE PEOPLE NEED TO
SPEAK UP LIKE YOU.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS REALITY
AND PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO HEAR
IT.
I'M SURE YOU'LL GET CRITICIZED
FOR IT BUT THAT COMES WITH THE
TERRITORY NOW.
>> THAT'S LIFE.
>> THIS IS FROM ABC NEWS.
71% OF REPUBLICANS DON'T BELIEVE
BIDEN WAS A LEGITIMATELY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THEY'RE NOT IN LINE WITH THE
OVERALL POPULATION WHERE 65% DO
BELIEVE BIDEN'S VICTORY WAS
LEGITIMATE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN WHEN ONE OF
THE TWO PARTIES, TWO MAJOR
PARTIES IN THIS COUNTRY, IS THIS
OUT OF STEP, THIS DELUSIONAL,
REALLY?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I SAW A POLL
THE OTHER DAY THAT INDICATED
THERE WERE BIG CHUNK OF
DEMOCRATS THAT THOUGHT THAT
TRUMP WAS NOT LEGITIMATELY
ELECTED BUT THIS IS REACHED A
FEVERED PITCH.
THIS IS WAY UP THERE.
AND AGAIN, DON, YOU KNOW, THE
THING THAT'S SO HARD ABOUT IT,
YOU AND I CAN'T LOSE OUR TEMPER.
WE GOT TO BE KIND TO THESE
PEOPLE WHO WE DISAGREE WITH
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO DRIVE
THEM AWAY.
THEY'VE GOT TO HAVE A REALITY
CHECK AND TO SAY THAT -- LOOK,
YOU HAD REPUBLICAN LEADERS, WHEN
THE LEADERS EARLY ON DIDN'T
ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF THIS
ELECTION, WHEN YOUR LEADERSHIP
FAILS, YOU KNOW, THEN THINGS
BEGIN TO FALL APART AND THE
LEADERS, A NUMBER OF THE LEADERS
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY DIDN'T
ADMIT JOE BIDEN WAS ELECTED.
HOW ABOUT THE DEBATE IN
MINNESOTA WHERE FIVE CANDIDATES
FOR GOVERNOR AND NONE WOULD SAY
BIDEN WAS LEGITIMATELY ELECTED.
SHAME ON THEM.
THAT'S A FIRST FOR POWER, DON.
WHEN YOU HAVE A THIRST FOR POWER
AND POWER AN END TO ITSELF, IT'S
TERRIBLE.
>> WELL, YOU MENTIONED --
LISTEN, THE CASE FOR 2016 FOR
ELECTION FRAUD IS A MUCH BETTER
CASE, NOT THAT -- YOU KNOW, NOT
SAYING EITHER ONE, TRUMP WAS NOT
LEGITIMATELY ELECTED BUT A MUCH
BETTER CASE IN 2016 THAN THERE
WAS FOR 2020.
I WANT TO PUT IT A DIFFERENT
WAY.
LOOK, NOBODY SEIZED THE CAPITOL
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
A MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS
ESSENTIALLY STILL BELIEVE WHAT
THE INSURRECTIONISTS BELIEVED OR
BELIEVE.
THE BIG LIE THAT THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN.
CERTAINLY SOUNDS LIKE NO MATTER
WHAT THIS COMMITTEE, THIS
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE UNCOVERS.
>> DOESN'T MATTER.
>> WE'LL BE IN THE SAME PLACE
THAT WE ARE NOW FOREVER.
>> DON, THERE -- WELL, I'M NOT
SURE IT WILL BE FOREVER, BUT
AGAIN, I'VE GOT TO JUST SAY THAT
THIS REPRESENTS A BREAK FROM
REALITY.
AND WHEN YOU GET INTO THAT AND
WHEN IT'S CULT LIKE AND YOU SAY
LOOK, I'M IN MY GROUP, I BELIEVE
THE ELECTION WAS NOT LEGITIMATE
AND I'VE GOT 50 OTHER FRIENDS
AND I'M ON SOCIAL MEDIA IN MY
OWN LITTLE CAVE THERE AND IF I
BEGIN TO SAY WELL, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE IT WAS A GOOD ELECTION,
THEY THROW ME OUT.
AND SO YOUR STRENGTH, YOUR
PURPOSE, YOUR BEING IS FROM THAT
GROUP AND YOU'RE BEING
OSTRACIZED.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
I GOT TO BELIEVE THE TRUTH WILL
PREVAIL.
WE GOT TO STAY ON THIS, DON, AND
HAVE THESE WARNING SIGNS AND
THESE KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS I
HOPE WITH YOU AND ME BECAUSE
PEOPLE WATCH US AND LIKE US WHEN
WE TALK.
I HOPE IT WILL GET THROUGH.
I HOPE PEOPLE WILL SEE IT AND
THINK TWICE ABOUT THEIR BEHAVIOR
BECAUSE THEIR BEHAVIOR
DETERMINES THE STRENGTH AND
FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> DO YOU EVER LISTEN TO
CONSERVATIVE RADIO?
I WENT HOME TO LOUISIANA AND
FLIPPING THROUGH -- OR EVEN THE
PROPAGANDA THAT IS ON THE FOX
PROPAGANDA NETWORK?
BECAUSE IT IS DISCONNECTED FROM
REALITY.
I FIND MYSELF -- I DON'T WATCH
FOX ANYMORE.
I USED TO WATCH.
I DON'T WATCH ANYMORE.
IT RIDICULOUS.
AS I WAS LISTENING, I FOUND
MYSELF FACT CHECKING THE PEOPLE
ONLY THE RADIO SAYING THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
THIS ISN'T TRUE.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
HOW DO YOU GET THROUGH TO
AMERICANS THAT ONLY LISTEN IN
THE SILOS THANKS ONLY LISTEN TO
THE FOX PROPAGANDA?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT OLD BOOK I
WROTE THE TEN MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS IN TERMS OF HOW YOU LIVE,
I TALK ABOUT THESE SILOS AND
PEOPLE NEED TO BREAK OUT OF THEM
AND WHEN THEY BROKE OUT OF THEM,
IT'S HARD FOR THEM BUT THEN
THEY'RE SO HAPPY THEY'RE ABLE TO
BE MORE OBJECTIVE, THEY WERE
ABLE TO HEAR OTHER THINGS BUT
AGAIN, THEY'RE COMFORTABLE BEING
IN THE SILO AND THAT'S DANGER ON
ALL SIDES, NOT JUST DANGER ON
THE RIGHT BUT DANGER ACCORD THE
BOARD BECAUSE WE'RE FIGHTING AND
HATING.
THAT'S NOT THE AMERICA WE NEW
YEARS AGO.
IT'S STUNNING TO ME.
>> YEAH AND THE FACTS DON'T
MATTER.
WHAT MATTERS IS --
>> THEY DON'T.
THINK FOR ONE SECOND ABOUT THESE
ELECTIONS.
HOW ABOUT AL GORE?
HE COULD HAVE DRIVEN THIS THING
INTO THE GROUND.
HE WAS A BIGGER MAN.
RICHARD NIXON.
THERE WAS A QUESTION ABOUT THAT
ELECTION.
HE SAID I'LL PUT THE COUNTRY
FIRST.
OUR LEADERS ARE NOT PUTTING THE
COUNTRY FIRST.
NOT ALL OF THEM BUT TOO MANY OF
THEM